[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Click the
Activate Google Cloud Shell
button at the top right
of the console window.
A Cloud Shell session
opens inside a new frame
at the bottom of the
console, and displays
a command line prompt.
It may take a few
seconds to initialize.
Once your Cloud Shell
session is ready to use,
you can do things like
go to your home directory
and use VI to view your
bashrc configuration.
In this Quick Start,
we'll preview and deploy
an App Engine application.
First, clone the
sample app, and run
it locally in the
Cloud Shell session
using the App Engine
development server.
Click the Web Preview
button, and then
select the port number
from the displayed menu.
Cloud Shell opens
the preview URL
at its proxy service in
a new browser window.
When you are done previewing
the App Engine app,
type Control-C to stop
the development server.
Now that we've
previewed our app,
we can deploy our App Engine
app using gcloud app deploy.
This may take a few
minutes to complete.
Once deployed, you can open your
application in the web browser.
The URL is at your project
ID dot appspot.com.
Now, if the application has
not yet finished deploying,
you'll see an error
message in the web browser.
Simply wait until deployment is
finished, and refresh the page.
Congratulations.
You've successfully
previewed and deployed
an App Engine app using
just your browser thanks
to the power of Cloud Shell.
[MUSIC PLAYING]